i want to start with just joining the
world of housewives
you are so beloved right away you're
like the fan favorite of season 11.
how is the fan response sitting with you
thank you i am really flattered and
very happy we've learned that you are
a little kooky you love a joke you love
a prank i want to talk about the
midnight madness moment
um in tahoe
why did you go into sutton's room first
maybe i was confused which room
who was where i don't really remember
and then going to kyle's room
like that wasn't a bit that's just what
you would do cameras or not right
well i i would think i'm gonna go to bed
in one minute
i think that was the night that we had
the burnt salmon
so i was a little hungry and
i didn't have my glasses on and
there wasn't anything where i could make
a sandwich
so all i could find was chips and a soft
drink and i
could see i know what a coca-cola and a
zero coke looks like
um so i just grabbed something
that i thought was just a soft drink
what are you out of your mind what is
this
a red bull i thought it was like just a
soft drink but moments like that moments
like you
walking into the the group holding your
mic pack it's not on people are saying
you know there's
kathy hilton energy um and there's memes
of like this is kathy hilton energy how
would you describe
kathy hilton energy well with the i i
don't even remember that with the mic
i was just coming from my room because i
probably took a
quick bathroom break and i had it
and then when i thought i would be on
then i would have tucked it back in
it gets really hot so i was holding it
and i didn't realize this is new to me
right but how would you describe kathy
hilton energy like what are the factors
of kathy hilton energy well i'm actually
just
seeing this for the first time um
anytime anybody's ever seen me on tv
there is this very serious side too
i have a serious side and so
this i'm comfortable i was just very
comfortable but it was really
interesting
for me to watch sometimes i can't watch
because i'll think oh my goodness i have
no makeup on how can i really let people
see me like this
you know we're getting the full picture
of who kathy hilton is
that is that's really me bottoms up
i feel like i first got a window into
this side of you
through your social media presence
because
you in the comment section it's always
an interesting journey kathy
you're leaving like long messages asking
people to set up lunch dates
to call you back do you realize everyone
can see everything you comment and post
there's times i didn't realize because i
really started getting familiar with the
computer
about two and a half three years ago i
do have to have somebody help me
with the post that's why i don't post
that often it's the house size of
beverly hills almost didn't happen it
was almost
a show around kim
kathy and kyle right kyle
yep that's right wow so 11 plus years
ago
when housewives was kind of first coming
i guess
kyle and kim's way there was a
discussion that you might be involved at
the time
and the show would focus on the three
sisters why
didn't that happen why did it shift to
housewives
we were we were working on a project and
kim said to me well we just
received an offer to do the housewives
or something so i said
why don't you just go ahead with that
because
this is a proven francis you know it's a
successful
show so go ahead with that and then it
took us a whole
decade plus to finally get you on this
show as a cast member
i just thought you know what i'm at a
point in my life where
hey it was cobit it was a little boring
and um when kyle was insistent and just
kept
on and the producer literally we went
back and forth back and forth
for three months and it was yes no it
was really more
no and then i thought well
so this was the perfect moment um and
getting to know some of these other
ladies who surprised you the most
i really wasn't surprised did anyone
disappoint you
no they didn't okay i think maybe i was
surprised
that i really genuinely liked each and
every one it's like a girls club i feel
like i'm a member
of a very special uh group of dynamic
women
that have their drama and
um i love to be in the middle of it well
yeah they
they say the world of housewives is kind
of a sorority and now that you've
gone through the cycle one time do you
think you would want to do it again
would you come back for season 12 would
you ever hold a diamond
i will never hold a diamond okay
ever that i can tell you i wouldn't have
time
and um we'll see there's 21 episodes so
there's another
15 episodes to watch so and a reunion to
experience
i don't know if i'll be in the reunion
i think he'll be there kathy really yeah
i would love to i would love are you
kidding
i would love to i think i think it'll
come to fruition kathy
um and people kind of getting to know
you a lot of people are finding out
things that
i've known about you for a long time but
i guess are news to people like
how close you are to the jackson family
um
did you and michael really have a pact
to name your first
daughter's paris you know when we were
little we talked about things i really
don't you know remember
do you think your pal latoya would ever
join housewives
i don't know maybe we've worked together
before
i did her show life with latoya i would
like to see more of that dynamic kathy
some like 3 a.m prank phone calls with
you and latoya
oh she's but michael and i used to make
them
i can only imagine in signing on to this
you were initially hesitant i know you
kept it
um from paris and nikki and they've been
very vocal about how they felt about
that
and by the way i'm not knocking the show
i love the show
i am a huge fan i find it
highly entertaining but if someone were
to ask me do you want your
mother being on it no
and the funny thing is believe it or not
my mom's never even seen the show
okay she doesn't even know what she's
getting into how do they feel
now though that the show is airing and
they're getting to see your experience
i don't know if paris has seen the show
but she did
send me some memes you know they're very
much they're proud and when they make a
decision
especially nikki she's not gonna
she's too proud to say oh it's so
fabulous and whatever and
like that she was wrong i know
that i'm not gonna go and be cursing and
starting fights with people so i didn't
understand why they would be
so concerned right i think not who i
am well i think people kids are just
protective of their
their mom what i found so interesting is
in watching you and seeing
this more casual side of you is so much
of paris's voice and mannerisms
is you kathy well i gave birth to her
[Laughter]
we are a lot alike that's the way we
like it
i remember they said on paris's podcast
they were talking about i think it's the
dinner that was in the trailer where
erica kind of gets um
tense with sutton that baron could hear
what was going
on at that table up in his room baron
told me
they were filming a few weeks ago at the
house
some dinner and he could hear the
shouting from his bedroom it's
great who mom
no not mom just i don't know you just
heard all the shouting
how tense and bad do things get at that
dinner kathy did get a little out of
hand
okay very
my assistant took a picture of baron
and his wife listening over their face
so i'm going to post that picture when
that episode comes up
they're like is there anything that we
the viewers need to be bracing for
impact for
as the rest of the season plays out i'd
put your seat belt
on tomorrow morning because tomorrow
night
is when the drama really kicks in
tomorrow night is when
the action starts as things picked up
did you ever go
oh god what have i gotten myself into
um yes i have
and so sometimes i get up and
go into another room smart go into the
refrigerator and
get something to eat just to get out for
a second do we have any
little treats to eat all right we'll
wrap things up with i know you said
you'll never hold a diamond
but do you have a tagline in mind i
would love to know what kathy hilton's
housewife's tagline would be
wow i i never thought of it
um what do you think there's probably
something
well i don't know you could go like i'm
the hostess with the mostest but don't
cross me
i love that or perception is not always
reality and i'll show you by crawling
into your bed at midnight with a red
bull
what is this a red bull i thought it was
like just a soft drink